The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TADGE DRYJA: Today we're going
to talk about wallets and SPV.
And if you don't
know what SPV stands
for, that will be defined
as well, so don't worry.
First, you get your software.
That's something of
a problem, like how
do you know you got the
right Bitcoin software,
there can be issues
there, but anyway--
there are multiple
implementations that
should be consensus compatible.
I often use BTCD, which is
a version written in Go,
but the main implementation
is written in c++.
So, you get the
software, and then
you somehow connect to
peers in the network,
but there's all these
asterisks, which
mean it's not completely
decentralized.
You have to find
where to get it,
you have to find
who to connect to.
Once you do that, you get
all the headers, which
are 80 bytes each, you
verify all the work,
and then you start
getting the blocks,
looking through
the transactions.
You replay the history of the
last nine years of the coin,
and then you arrive
at a UTXO set,
an unspent transaction
output set,
and it should be the same
as everyone else got.
Everyone else has the same
headers, the same work,
the same transactions.
They'll get the same set of
which coins are encumbered
by which keys as you do.
And the idea is it would
be very expensive to have
different UTXO sets because
you'd have to do all that work.
So that's how a node works.
But what about dealing
with actual money?
So far, we've just
looked at here's
how to get your
node running, here's
how to observe the
network and come
to the same conclusion
as everyone else,
but you probably want
to actually do something
with this.
You want to pay
people or get paid.
Those are the two
fundamental functions
that this tries to address.
So the software that manages
this feature is called
a wallet, and it's
not necessarily
the same software as what's
connecting to the network,
downloading, and verifying.
In the case of
Bitcoin Core, it is,
although many of the programmers
of Bitcoin Core wish that it
weren't.
And there's sort
of a long-term goal
of, it'd be really great
if we could pull these two
things apart into maybe separate
binaries, separate programs,
something.
But they're really intertwined,
and it's kind of ugly.
But there are other
things that are separate
OK, so wallet software
functionality-- seems simple,
you send and receive money.
Simple.
Of course, you need to receive
money before you can send it,
so let's start with that.
OK, so we did not talk
about receive addresses.
We did talk about the script,
and how it's generally
used pay to pubkey hash, where
you put the hash of your pubkey
in your output script, and
then in your redeem script,
in your input,
you put the pubkey
itself, which is then
checked against the hash,
and then the
signature is verified.
Most likely, if you've
looked at Bitcoin at all,
you've seen these
types of addresses.
They usually start with 1,
they're a bunch of characters
long, a weird mix of lowercase,
uppercase, Latin numbers,
and letters.
There is a standard for
converting a 20-byte pubkey
hash into this address.
So the idea is since
almost everything
is using the same
pubkey hash script,
you can forget
about the opcodes,
like op_dup, op_hash160,
op_equalverify
because they're always the same.
And so it's this standard,
like, OK we're just
taking that 20-byte
hash, and now
let's convert it to
something hopefully somewhat
human readable and writeable so
that people can write it down,
say it over the phone.
This is the one Satoshi made.
It's got 58 characters
and then the last 4 bytes,
which ends up being like
5 or 6 of the letters,
is sort of a checksum,
where you take
the hash of the first
however many letters
and then that's supposed to
like equal to the next one.
So, hopefully, if you
typed something wrong,
it doesn't change
the hash and then
you send it to the wrong
place and then no one has
a matching key for that.
There's a newer
standard for this
where all the all the
letters are lowercase.
That's introduced, actually,
today in Bitcoin Core.
Version 0.16 came
out, and so there's
a new standard called Bech32.
They did some research,
and they found
it was actually much
faster to transmit over
the phone via voice
because you didn't
have to say whether things
were uppercase or lowercase,
which ended up being
very annoying for people,
because, you know, 1 big F,
a little f, 1, 2, big E, 4--
it's annoying.
Anyway, the idea is
this is just an encoding
of the 20-byte pubkey
hash, so when you type this
into a program, it
reads this, converts it
into a 20-byte hash,
builds the output script.
OK, so the outputs
are all the same.
So this is sort of
like a UI thing.
The addresses don't really
exist at the protocol level.
Any questions about addresses?
OK.
We're not going to put--
UI and usability is
super important, but not
the focus yet of
what we're doing.
The idea, in a lot
of cases, is you
want to receive money and
know that you received it,
or somehow interact with
people over computers,
and you could put a bunch
of addresses on a server,
but keep your
private keys offline.
Because if you keep both your
public key and your private key
on the same computer, that's
kind of an attractive target
for someone to break into
your system because they say,
oh, this guy's running Bitcoin
and he's accepting payments.
There might be a bunch
of money in this computer
if I can get into it.
I can take all the money.
So one issue that people ran
up against pretty early is--
well, let's say I
generate 10 keys--
10 private keys, 10
public keys, 10 addresses.
I put them on the
server, then I run out.
And I can reuse addresses,
but that can hurt privacy
because people can then see
that the same people are
using these keys.
So is there any clever way
we can generate pubkeys
without the private key?
Is there, given all the fun
key stuff we've talked about,
can anyone think of any
clever ways to do that?
OK, well pretty straightforward.
This is called BIP32, Bitcoin
Improvement Proposal 32.
This is a
super-simplified version,
but this is the basic
idea of what they do,
and they do it much more
involved and complicated.
But basically, you've
got your public key P--
big P-- and some kind
of randomized data--
randomizer data, r and your
private key is just little p.
So the idea is you want
to send to an address,
you want to generate
a new address.
Well, it's just your public key
plus the hash of r concatenated
with 1 times G. And if you
wanted to make this 2, 3,
you can make this
any number you want.
And then your
private key is just
going to be that same public
key plus the hash of r.
So you give someone
some extra data,
which they can throw
into a hash function.
Use this as a known
private key and you add it
to your private key.
So no one just knowing this
data can spend from it.
That's really nice
because then the server
can generate arbitrary numbers.
Does this make sense?
AUDIENCE: What's the
difference big A and a?
TADGE DRYJA: Oh, yes.
So in the last one,
big A is a public key.
It's a point on the curve.
Little a is the private key.
I screwed that up.
That does not have a G. So G
is the generator for the group.
G is how you convert from a
private key to a public key.
You just multiply by G, which
is just an arbitrary point.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So your private
key doesn't change?
TADGE DRYJA: So in this case,
there's two private keys.
There's your
standard private key
that you actually just randomly
created-- this number p,
multiply it by G, to get
big P. But your private key
for any particular
address does change.
You're adding the hash
of r, 1 or r, 2, r,3.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Assuming the size
of r is relatively small
compared to p because
don't you have to keep
track of the nonce?
TADGE DRYJA: R should be,
like, 32 bytes or something.
You know, you don't want any--
AUDIENCE: Do you have to start
with it every time that you
create a new hash code?
TADGE DRYJA: You sort of don't.
What you can do is,
you have your server.
You say, hey, I'm
going to accept
payments for cookies or shoes
or whatever I'm selling.
And then you give the
server your public key, P,
and the randomizer r, and
you just say to the server,
go wild, make whatever
number you want here.
This number should
be fairly small,
let's say less than a billion.
And then when you want to find
how much you've gotten paid,
well, you can generate a
billion private keys here--
some reasonable number that the
computer can actually do it--
and you could just
increment this,
generate a ton of
addresses, and look for them
on the blockchain.
So does that makes sense at all?
BIP32 is actually quite a bit
more involved and complicated.
This is the basic idea,
but they make trees of it,
and you can say, oh,
well, we can make instead
of just one level, we can make
a whole tree of these things,
and have different
accounts, and make
a really full-featured
system in case people
want to use this kind of thing.
So you can put the public
key and this random data
on the server.
The server can make addresses
as needed, really quickly.
And what's nice is observers
can't link these addresses.
If you're just looking
at the blockchain,
you won't see the difference
between a sub 1 and a sub 2,
if this number and
1 and 2 because it's
going through this hash
function, you never see that.
To an observer, it looks
like all completely different
addresses.
And if someone hacks
into the server
and finds this P point, and
this r randomizer, well,
that will allow them
to link everything.
Now they can see--
oh, we can also
generate all these addresses.
We can see that it's
all the same person.
But that doesn't let them
steal any of the funds.
So compromising the
server with this, well,
you lose the privacy, but
you don't lose your money,
so that's a pretty good trade.
Other questions about BIP32?
So that's one of the
features for wallets.
You've got to do this.
The basic procedure-- you're
going to request a payment.
And you're going to say, hey,
if you want this jacket, send
one coin to address F8f12E.
And it's sort of important to
note that Bitcoin doesn't solve
the problem of people
paying money and not
getting what they paid for.
That's out of the scope
of this, although there's
a lot of people
that say it should,
but know it doesn't
do fraud protection.
It's like, hey, I
gave you the coin,
you didn't give me the jacket.
Well, Bitcoin worked fine.
Bitcoin made the coin move.
That's Bitcoin's job.
The fact that FedEx never
delivered your jacket,
well, that's FedEx
or the retailer
or all sorts of
things like that.
You know, I don't want to
say it's not a problem.
It certainly is, but it
is seen as out of scope.
It's, like, you know--
this is a money system.
This is money.
Your dollar bills don't
ensure that you're
getting what you paid for.
That said, there's
all sorts of things
that do this kind of thing,
and do try to ensure delivery
versus payment--
atomic swaps, HTLCs that
we'll talk about later,
Zero-Knowledge
Contingent Proof--
all these different things do
sort of work on top of Bitcoin
to try to help these
kinds of things.
In practice, though,
if you're actually
buying a physical
jacket that someone's
going to deliver to
you, there's not really
a good cryptographic
proof of jacket delivery.
So some reputation is involved.
Then, from the
merchant's perspective--
so, I sell jackets.
I want to know if
someone paid me.
I have something on the
website, put in your address,
now pay this address.
So you add all
your pubkey hashes
to a big list in your software.
You say, OK, here's all
the addresses I've created.
They're all these
20-byte pubkey hashes.
I put them in a map or some
kind of array or some database,
whatever.
And from then on,
every transaction I
see on the network, I also
look at the output scripts.
So before, when I was
verifying the blockchain,
I actually never had to
look at the output scripts
until they got spent.
So when I was
downloading transactions,
I would look at their
signatures and look
at the old UTXOs in the UTXO set
and match them up and verify.
But where the money got sent
in these new transactions,
I didn't really care.
It could have been
sending it to zero.
It could have been sending
it to some weird address that
probably was wrong.
There was no-- and I
believe to this day,
there's still no
output validation
that happens in Bitcoin
as a consensus rule
because it's not important.
Where are you sending the money?
Well, wherever you want.
And are you able to spend it?
We'll deal with that later.
If you want to destroy
your money, fine.
I'm not going to
look at the output.
There's no invalid output.
There can be an
invalid input, which--
there can be an output which
you can never actually use,
but you're free to send to it.
So that's sort of one
of the rules in Bitcoin.
However, when we're
actually looking
at our own money
with the wallet,
we do look at the output
scripts, mainly to say, hey,
is this ours?
Are we getting paid
with this transaction?
So you look at
every output script,
and if you see one that
matches, hey, we got paid.
So you see a transaction,
one of the outputs--
hey, look, that 20
bytes-- that's me.
Cool.
That's one of the
addresses that I have,
let me keep track of this.
This is now money
that's in my wallet.
So you keep track of
the received payments,
you save them to disk in a
similar way to your addresses.
You use some kind of
database or map or something,
something efficient.
And then you don't need to
save too much information.
You need to save the
outpoint, the txid
of the transaction, the index.
You probably want to save how
much, your amount, and which
key it was, so the actual
20-byte pubkey hash.
You can look through
all your keys,
but it might be nice--
oh, that's my 17th key
that I've saved in my
database or something.
You may also want to save
the height information, when
it got confirmed.
So we're not going to talk too
much about unconfirmed versus
confirmed today, but
this can be an issue
if you see a transaction on
the network that's not yet
in a block and it pays you.
You're like, hey, I got money,
but it's not confirmed yet,
so have I really gotten money?
I am able to use that output
to spend somewhere else,
but now I've got two change
transactions, neither of which
is confirmed.
And now the second
one can only be
confirmed if the
first one is, so that
can get ugly kind of quick.
For simplicity's
sake, let's just
say that you wait
until it's in a block
before your wallet
recognizes it.
Most wallets do not do that,
but most wallets maybe should.
There can be a lot
of weird attacks
where you say, oh, I
got money, and then
since it never really
was confirmed at all,
it's pretty easy for
someone to double spend.
The whole point of
the Bitcoin system
was you can't double
spend because it's
got all this proof
of work on top of it.
It's in a block.
But if we show in the UI, hey
you got a payment that has not
yet gone into a
block, well, there's
no assurance that it won't be
double spent yet, because it's
not in the blockchain.
But most wallets will show
that and usually they'll
make it in like red, or put
a little exclamation point
or something to try to indicate,
hey, this is unconfirmed,
but that doesn't always
get across to people.
So it may be safer to
just not show it at all
until it's in the block.
OK, so you amass
all these you UTXOs,
you're running your node, you've
got all these addresses you've
given out to people, and
then every transaction
that comes in you look--
hey, do any of these pay me?
And sometimes you'll find one
that does, which is great.
And then you save that
to your disk and, great.
Now, next, I want to spend them.
OK, any questions about the
getting money procedure?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, what's
the height again?
TADGE DRYJA: The height
is what block it's in,
so height zero is the
first block, zero block,
and we're now at height 500,000.
Usually, in diagrams,
it goes this way,
but I guess it could go up
in numbers, I don't know.
Yeah, so next, you
need to spend them.
Spending makes sense, right?
It's not too crazy.
Let's say you want to
send six coins to someone.
So what you do is, you look
through your set of UTXOs
that are your UTXOs, and
you try to find some such
that the total number
of coins is over six,
and then you use them as inputs,
and then you add your outputs.
So, for example,
I've got two UTXOs.
These are much smaller
numbers, but this one
has five coins in it and
this one has three coins.
So I received, at
two different times,
once I got five coins
for a fancy jacket,
once I got three coins
for a less fancy jacket.
And now I want to buy something,
and I want to send it to Bob,
and I want to send six coins.
Well, I've got eight
coins in my inputs,
so I'll send him six coins.
There's two coins leftover.
If I don't have this, it
just goes to the miners,
so I create my new output,
which is my change output.
And then I send the
remainder, two coins here.
Now, if it's actually
these nice, round numbers,
the fee would be zero
and it would probably not
get confirmed on
the Bitcoin network.
You do have to have a
small fee right now.
It's really small, like
a couple of cents now.
It was pretty high
a few months ago.
But this will work.
This is the basic idea.
So, you look through
your UTXOs, find
some, OK, output six,
output two, sign them.
Once you've built this, sign it
all, broadcast to the network.
Make sense?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is the change
UTXO, like, your own?
TADGE DRYJA: Yep.
Yep.
Generally, what you'll do is,
you'll make a new private key,
calculate the public key,
hash it, make this address,
and then add it in
here, all automatically.
You can, and some
software does, just
only use one key
and one address,
and so it'll be pretty
clear because the keys
for this signature will
be the same as this key
that it's sending to, and
so then it's really clear.
Even without doing that,
it's usually pretty clear
and people can sort of
guess, well, either Alice
is sending six coins back to
herself and two coins to Bob,
or she's sending six coins to
Bob and two back to herself.
Or maybe six coins to
one person, two coins
to someone else entirely.
That's pretty unlikely.
Usually, metrics will try to
analyze the transaction graph,
and say, oh, the smaller
outputs are usually the payments
and the larger ones
are the change,
but you don't know if the
addresses are all different.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How does the
fee get paid again?
TADGE DRYJA: The fee
is the difference
between the inputs amounts
and the output amounts.
So, in this case,
the fee is zero
because I got 5, 3,
8, and then 8 here.
So, really, what you do in real
life is, you'd make this 1.999
and then the fee would be
that 0.001, or whatever
that the miner gets in
the coinbase transaction.
That's another way to try
to identify change outputs.
If you actually had
5, 3, 6, and 1.999,
I bet the 1.999 is
going back to yourself.
Nice, even, round numbers
seem like real payments.
And then if you've got one
bunch of nines at the end,
oh, that was probably
just reduced a little
to make the fee.
But these are all guesses.
If you're a third party observer
looking at a transaction,
you don't know.
This could be two
different people,
or this could be an exchange
and it's hard to tell,
but you can get some
pretty good guesses.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In terms of
fees, so if you have no fee
or you had a really
small fee and buyers
are requiring something
higher, that just
sits on everyone's computer.
They still share with each
other or do they sit there
until maybe there's a block?
TADGE DRYJA: There are
multiple thresholds.
So, there's the relay
threshold, which right now I
believe Bitcoin is
one Satoshi per byte.
So, I think we said
Satoshis are the smallest
unit possible in Bitcoin.
So one coin is actually
100 million Satoshis--
and there's no decimal places,
that's just a UI thing.
So right now, the minimum
relay fee, by default,
is 1 Satoshi per byte.
So for a 250-byte transaction,
you need 250 Satoshis,
which is some
fraction of a cent--
maybe more than a cent
now, I'm not sure.
And then the idea is if you
see a transaction below that,
you won't even relay
it to anyone else.
You'll be like, this is
so cheap that I'm not
going to bother sending
it to everyone else.
I'm just going to ignore it.
But above that 1
Satoshi threshold,
you will accept it,
verify the signatures,
and then pass it on to everyone
else you're connected to.
But that doesn't necessarily
mean it will get into a block
anytime soon.
It's actually been really
interesting the last,
I'd say six months, where
the fees went up enormously
and you see this really
crazy price inelasticity,
where people who were
paying one cent then
started paying 10 cents,
a dollar, $10, $20.
And what's also
sort of optimistic--
that made me feel
good-- it's like, well,
clearly they were getting
20 bucks worth of utility
out of this because
they're now perfectly
willing to pay 20 bucks and
they were paying one cent
a few weeks ago.
That's kind of weird.
And then it's now gone back
down to, like, one cent.
But it's very inelastic
in that there's
a fixed size for how
many transactions
you can have per
minute or per hour
and when people really
want to get in there,
they have to just bid
everyone else out.
So we'll talk about the
fee markets in a few weeks,
and replace by fee.
That's sort of a
new evolving thing,
but it's been really interesting
to see in the last few months
how it's changed.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: At
$10,000 per Bitcoin,
a Satoshi is 0.01
cent, a hundredth--
TADGE DRYJA: Tenth of a cent.
AUDIENCE: Hundredth of a cent.
TADGE DRYJA:
Hundredth of a cent.
OK.
So, the minimum relay fee would
be more like 2 and 1/2 cents.
So that's-- you
know, it's not zero.
That's still-- a fee, right?
And you get enough of those
and you start making money.
But it's also
interesting recently, it
used to be that the initial
new coins coming out to miners
was just overwhelmingly
the majority of what
they had earned and people
would ignore fees as a miner.
But then, in
December, January, I
believe miners made more money
in fees than in new coins being
generated.
I'm not sure if
that averages out.
There were definitely
weeks where
that was the case,
or at least days,
I'm not sure if it's
average or the whole month.
But if you-- total aside,
sorry, but this guy's site
is a cool way to
look at the fees.
So you can see here's--
he sort of organizes
transactions by fee rate.
It's too low-res to
really get everything,
but if you just
search for Johoe--
J-O-H-O-E-- he works on Bitcoin
stuff and he made this cool
site, which is open source
and you could even run it
on your own node if you wanted
to, and generate the same cool
JavaScript color-y things and
you can see the fee market.
And I'm not an economist,
but it is really interesting
seeing there's clearly market
failures occurring here
in that--
so, you can pay the green--
you can pay 10
Satoshis per byte,
and you'll get
confirmed in 10 minutes.
Or you can pay 1,000
Satoshis per byte,
and you will also get
confirmed in 10 minutes.
And most people are paying 10,
but someone's paying 1,000.
You know, it's got
the whole spectrum.
You've got multiple
orders of magnitude
of people paying for
the exact same thing,
and they can all see each other.
It's just a weird sort of--
seems broken.
And part of it is just the
cost to write the software.
If you're an exchange
and everyone's
sending you support
requests, and this happens--
OK, I don't know just, pay
a 500 Satoshi per byte fee--
and then it seems to work.
And, yeah, we're losing a
couple of thousand bucks a day,
but let's just not
deal with that.
And I think that's
part of it, is
that there's a lot
of software out there
that just has a fixed fee
rate, or even a fixed fee,
regardless of how big
the transaction is.
There's a lot of software
that, years ago, wouldn't
have to deal with this issue
because there wasn't really
competition to get into
a block, and now they do.
So it's kind of cool to look
at and see the history of it.
But I'll get into depth of
fees and stuff in, I think,
two weeks or something.
OK, any questions about--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: What was
that website again?
TADGE DRYJA: Well, it's in
some Dutch, or something.
Just search J-O-H-O-E, Johoe.
He's the guy.
It's the first thing on Google.
J-O-H-O-E is his Dutch nickname,
or something, I don't know.
He's a cool guy.
He actually-- I
think I talked-- did
I talk-- there was
some randomness
problems at some site.
He stole a bunch of Bitcoins and
gave them back to their owners.
He found there was a K
reuse, like nonce reuse
vulnerability in some wallets.
And so he's like, hey, look,
there's like 100 Bitcoins
that I can just take because I
can calculate the private key.
And he took them,
and he was like, I
think I know who these
are and can you prove it,
and then I'll give them back?
So he sort of grabbed-- you
know, finding a wallet with,
like, thousands of dollars
coming out of it on the street,
he grabbed them all and tried
to get them back to people.
I don't know the guy.
I've never met him but
seems like a nice guy.
Anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
That's how Bitcoin works.
You don't meet anyone,
but you see these people--
oh he's a nice guy.
Oh, he's a jerk.
The weekend was kind of
interesting over Twitter,
but anyway--
AUDIENCE: I saw that.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
OK, so you build
these transactions.
There are issues here.
Two inputs, two outputs--
that's going to be kind of big.
You're going to have two
different signatures.
It's going to be a
little bit higher fee.
What would work
better than this?
It's kind of a silly question.
What would work
better than having
two inputs and two outputs
to make this transaction
to pay someone six coins?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe if you wanted
to have an anonymous transaction
doing something like multiple
transactions in smaller sizes?
TADGE DRYJA: Sure.
Yeah, that's-- you could send--
so, that's actually two slides
from now.
The next slide was
just, well, what
if you had a UTXO that was
exactly the right size?
Then it's easy.
You just send them
the six coins.
If you have the exact right
size UTXO in your wallet, great.
You just send it over.
It's like if you go to a
shop and they're like, OK,
that's $10 for lunch.
You're like, great,
I have a $10 bill.
Here it is.
We don't need to deal with
pennies and quarters and stuff.
It's annoying.
So sometimes this happens.
It's great.
Generally, it won't.
Generally, you will have change
and multiple inputs and outputs
and it's kind of annoying.
So coin selection
is a tricky problem.
For CSE terms it's
NP-hard, actually,
but there's heuristics
that work OK.
If you have a ton
of UTXOs and you
have to send these
payments, you can actually,
in a reasonable amount of
time, calculate the optimal way
to do it.
But there's some
heuristics at work,
and the question is what
are we optimizing for?
Generally, you
want to optimize--
minimize the number
of inputs used.
The inputs are much
bigger, they're
going to be like a
hundred something bytes,
and the outputs
are pretty small,
they're like 20-30 bytes.
So if you want to minimize
size of your transaction,
minimize the number of
inputs, which is easy.
You just pick your biggest
UTXO and spend that one.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it like the
knapsack problem, though?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, it
basically is, yeah.
Well, because it's
multi-iteration,
if you're just trying to
optimize your transaction right
now, you just use
your biggest UTXO.
So for example, it's sort
of the analogy of you're
at a checkout counter
and someone says,
OK, that's $12.93.
If you want to minimize
the number of bills
you're handing to
the cashier, you just
take the 100 out of your wallet.
That'll always work.
You just say, I take my biggest
bill, hand it to you, OK,
I'm minimizing the amount
of bills I'm handing you
in this one transaction.
However, that could result in
a whole bunch of bills coming
back, a bunch of weird change.
And then also, long-term
that doesn't work.
If your strategy is always
just hand over the 100,
or you go through your
wallet and just hand
over the biggest bill
you have every time,
no matter what they ask,
that's super suboptimal
because if they say $12.93,
and you have a 20 and 100
and you hand over the 100
like, why did you do that?
And then you're going
to have four 20s.
So, it's very similar
to that, except now
that the change and bills
have arbitrary denominations.
There isn't a fixed--
you have 100s,
50s, 20s, 10s, 5s.
Now it can be any number.
So if you're just
looking at one time,
just pick your
biggest UTXO, you'll
have the smallest transaction.
But you want to
minimize next time,
so you ideally can
eliminate the change output
and get you a perfect target.
It's actually
really complicated.
There's really cool
research on how do we
select coins for long term?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So why don't
you just take the biggest
UTXO that's larger--
or, the smallest UTXO that's
larger than your output size?
TADGE DRYJA: Yep, that can work.
That's not-- that's
a good heuristic.
That's a good-- pretty easy
to code, sort your UTXOs,
go here, use that one.
It's not really
optimal because then--
it's a lot better
than taking big ones--
what do I have in my wallet?
So I've actually written an
SPV wallet and all this stuff
just from scratch, and
it's kind of interesting.
You learn a lot
about how it works.
I target two inputs
instead of one,
because then eventually-- if
you do that, what will happen
is you're going to be using
one input, which is great,
and then you're going to
run out of big inputs.
And then you're going to always
have to use two or three,
and you can get a lot of dust.
Dust is like the colloquial term
for really small UTXOs, where
you've got a bunch of pennies.
So that's one issue.
Another issue is
privacy concerns.
When you use two UTXOs
or have two inputs
in the same transaction, that's
linking those transactions,
linking those two UTXOs.
It's not definitive.
You can interactively create
transactions with other people.
In practice, that
doesn't happen.
You could say, hey, I want
to pay Alice five coins,
and you want to
pay Bob six coins,
and let's put my two
UTXOs and your two UTXOs
and we'll pay these two people,
and we'll put our own change
outputs, and we'll sort of
mix this transaction together
and we'll all sign it.
And you can do that
securely since you only
sign when it all
looks right to you,
and everyone only
signs when it's done.
But the coordination
problem is pretty severe.
You have to find other people
who want to make transactions
at the same time that you do.
It's annoying.
So, in practice, since you're
just using your wallet,
if you see a transaction
with multiple inputs,
you can you can
surmise, OK, those
are the same person
or the same company.
And if you want privacy, if
you want maximum anonymity
what kind of coin selection or
payment strategy would you use?
AUDIENCE: Would you make
just a bunch of transactions?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
If someone says, hey,
pay me six coins,
well I have these
three inputs, and I'm
paying you two coins
here and one coin here,
and three coins here.
And I paid you six coins but
in three completely separate
transactions.
That no one does either
because it's annoying.
You could.
It would be the most
anonymous, but even then,
what if they all happened
at the same time,
and you see they all
get in the same block?
And you're like,
OK, well they're
not linked nearly
as closely, but I
am seeing that these three
transactions happened
temporally similar times.
So there's all sorts of
things to try to optimize for.
OK, any other
questions about-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So does this mean
that every time people are going
to have a smaller and
smaller split of a Bitcoin
in their wallets?
They're just going to have
smaller and smaller amounts
because you're going to--
if you have a $100 bill
and then you're paying
$20, then you're going
to get four other $20 bills.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Eventually you're
just going to have smaller
and smaller-- is that a
fair implication, or--
TADGE DRYJA: OK,
short-term, yes.
If you start out with a bunch of
coins then start using it, yes.
But it does reach
equilibrium in that
let's say you've got all
these little tiny outputs--
you've got all these $1 bills--
but then you need to buy
something that is 20 bucks.
You have 20 inputs
and one output.
And whoever you're sending to
now gets that one big output.
And so, yeah, if you
graph that over time,
initially everyone was getting--
all their outputs
were 50 coins each
because that's how
you mined them.
And now they're getting
smaller, but there
is sort of an equilibrium after
you've used it for a while.
Any other questions about
sort of coin selection,
UTXO selection?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: According
to a news report,
I guess if you
[INAUDIBLE] transaction,
you also have
[INAUDIBLE] transactions.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, yeah.
So that's costly.
That's another reason
probably people don't do this.
I think the biggest reason is
it's just annoying to code,
and you can have
failures where like--
here, give me six coins.
OK, I'll give you 3, 2, and 1.
Oh, the 3 didn't work,
but the 2 and 1 did.
Well, now what do we do?
You paid me half of it.
It's nice to have all
or nothing payments.
And also we have to send
different addresses.
There's all sorts of things.
Also, it will be higher fees.
In practice, it's
actually not much higher.
Let's say having three one
input, one output transactions
versus one three input,
three output transaction--
you don't save too much space.
Most of the space is
taken by the inputs.
And the overhead
for a transaction
is only 10 or 20
bytes or something,
so it is not a huge difference.
The main difference
is that you're never
coalescing into
larger output sizes,
so you're going to always
have to sign since you going
to have more inputs overall.
This is a really,
kind of, cool problem.
There's a lot of
computer science-y stuff
but a lot of heuristics
and how people use it.
Also, the fact that fees
are variable over time
means you might want different
strategies when fees are
low versus when fees are high.
So when fees are low
now, I should make--
or maybe I just make a
transaction to myself
where I condense all my little
$2 outputs into one big $1,000
output so that when, later
on, if fees are higher,
I want to spend my money, I
can do so more efficiently.
And there is evidence of
this with exchanges and stuff
where a lot of times fees
will be lower on the weekends
because people aren't buying
and spending Bitcoin as much,
I guess.
And so certain companies would
say, OK, over the weekends
we're going to sort of condense
all our UTXOs and combine them
and then we can make smaller
transactions during the week.
So there's all sorts of
cool strategies here.
It's an interesting topic.
I haven't gone super in-depth,
but the guys that chain code
work on it.
There's a lot of discussion
about it, so it's kind of cool.
OK, I'm a little bit behind.
OK, next we'll talk
about losing money,
and that's another
really important part
of detecting the blockchain.
It's hard to do, but you have to
detect when you've lost money.
And it's tricky because
just because you
signed the transaction doesn't
really mean your money is gone.
You can't just unilaterally
say, OK, well, I'm making this.
I signed it.
There, my money is
gone from my wallet.
Well, not necessarily.
Maybe this never gets confirmed.
So maybe you still
have that money.
So you broadcast
it, but you sort of
have to wait until
it gets into a block,
and you also need to
listen for your own UTXOs,
even if you haven't
made a transaction,
and see if they've gotten spent.
And why would that be?
Can anyone think
of a reason why?
I haven't signed anything, as
far as my program is concerned,
but I might lose money anyway.
Why would that be?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, one
reason is you get hacked.
TADGE DRYJA: Sure,
you get hacked.
That's the bad reason.
A good reason is, well maybe
you have the same wallet
on multiple computers.
You've got the same keys.
So, getting hacked is sort
of a malicious instance
of this problem where I
thought the wallet was only
on my computer, but actually,
someone else has a copy.
But even non-maliciously,
I've got a copy on my phone
and I've got a copy
on my computer.
It's the same addresses, the
same keys, the same UTXOs.
That's totally doable.
And then when I spend money with
my phone and get to my desktop,
my desktop needs
to sort of download
and see oh, money got--
you know, you lost money.
And it's like, oh, yeah, yeah,
I remember spending that.
So you can have that
over multiple computers.
So if you're designing
wallet software,
you do definitely
need to make sure
that even if it's unexpected
from the wallet itself,
and it doesn't seem like
I generated a transaction,
there can still be a transaction
taking your money away.
Wallets without Bitcoin, and
that's sort of a cheeky phrase.
OK, I don't mean they don't have
any Bitcoins in their wallets,
I mean they're not running
Bitcoin in the same sense
that we've talked of.
So we talked about running
Bitcoin where you download
the software, you
get the headers,
you verify all the signatures,
you build the UTXO set.
Can you use Bitcoin
without doing this?
What do you guys think?
What's a simple way to
possibly use Bitcoin
without having to
do all these things?
So, a really, really simple way?
If you don't want
to do work, what's
the simplest way to
not have to do work?
Get someone else
to do it, right.
So, for example,
my dad has Bitcoin,
but he just gives it-- he's
like, you deal with it.
So I've got a couple
of Bitcoins that's
my dad's, and I have
to make sure like,
no, this is not my money.
Yeah, get someone
else to do it, right?
So that's what we're going to
talk about, the different ways
to get someone else to do this.
And what we called
before, running Bitcoin,
many now call a "full node."
And there's also the idea of
a "light node" or "SPV node,"
which we'll talk about.
Some people don't really
like this distinction,
and it's like, well, wait.
Full node is running Bitcoin.
These other things, we shouldn't
have to call it a full node.
We should just call
this a Bitcoin node
and these other things
are not quite there.
I will prefix there's
a lot of argument
about terms in this space.
So there's some people who
say, SPV doesn't exist.
And other people,
this isn't SPV.
So people argue about the words.
It's not like we have really
nice, definitive terms.
I'm generally trying to use
the most widely used terms,
but there's probably
people who will take issue
with it, so sorry.
So, SPV is sort of a step
down below running a full node
in terms of security.
It's called Simplified
Payment Verification.
It's written up in the
white paper on how to do it.
And you can verify all
the work without doing
too much signature verification
or having too much data.
So the basic idea
is you're optimizing
for not having to
download as much
and not having to store as much
at the cost of some security,
and I'll talk about those costs.
OK, so before we have this list
of what you do for a full node,
the SPV method is
a bit different.
You still do the same
part in the beginning.
You connect, you
get your headers,
you verify all the work.
OK, cool.
The next step, you
tell another node
that you're connected to
all of your addresses,
all of the public keys
that you've ever generated.
You tell it to them.
Then, for each header
you go through--
and instead of downloading
the whole block
and getting all the
transactions and verifying them,
you ask the other node,
hey, did I get any money,
or did I lose any
money in this block
because I've told
you all my addresses?
Oh, sorry.
You also tell them
all your UTXOs.
You also tell him, here's
all the money I have,
here's all the addresses I
could possibly receive money on,
did I get or lose any
money in this block?
And then they will return
to you a Merkle proof
of the transactions
where they think,
yeah, you got some
money here, or yeah,
you lost some money here,
and you can verify this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the
other nodes' incentive
to respond to you?
TADGE DRYJA: There is none.
You're not paying them.
They don't know who you are.
There's sort of a
meta incentive in that
I run a node that will
provide these Merkle
proofs because it's like,
well, it helps Bitcoin,
and maybe if I have
some Bitcoin and I'm
helping other people use it,
my Bitcoin will be worth more.
But that's a pretty
diffuse sort of thing.
And it can be problematic
because some of these things--
I didn't mention that in these
slides, but the server side can
get a little bit
costly in terms of CPU
because you're potentially--
as a server-- the
client requests hey,
here's this block.
Can you filter it for me, find
things that I'm looking for.
So now you have to load
that block into memory,
look through it.
It's not too CPU intensive,
but it can be-- you know,
when you have a bunch of
them, like 20 or 30 of them
connecting to you--
I've gotten 30%, 40% CPU
for doing this kind of thing
to serve other users.
Most-- almost all
phone wallets-- well,
many phone wallets and many
desktop wallets are using this
model, and so you'll see--
for example, so here's a
full node in this building.
I actually rebooted it
recently, so there's not
very many connections incoming.
In practice, these two are
actual full nodes, I bet.
This is a fake node.
This is-- they're
all fake, yeah.
Well, sorry-- these are all--
no, that one may be not.
Well, you can look.
But a lot of nodes will say
they're nodes and they're not,
and they're just trying to
track where transactions
are coming from and keep
track tabs on you and stuff.
And these are SPV
nodes, these bitcore,
because they don't
really ask for--
I don't know what they're doing.
They're not asking for anything.
So you can look through
all the messages.
I think Ethan will talk about
this a bit more Wednesday,
but there are a
lot of SPV nodes.
There's a lot of stuff
out on the network
and you have no idea
what it's doing,
but it's pretty clearly
not running a Bitcoin node.
So, yeah so I'll go through
these steps a little bit.
Oh, yeah.
So the Merkle verification we
talked about last week, where,
if there's a block and there's
thousands of transactions in it
and this server wants to prove
that one of these transactions
is yours and is in there, you
say, OK, here's my transaction.
They just need to provide you
this transaction ID, this hash,
and then you're able to see,
OK, yeah, it was in the header.
So my transaction is in there,
you're not just making it up.
I didn't talk about
the good part.
Well, the good part
is you don't really
need to maintain a UTXO
set and it's pretty small,
so it saves space, saves time.
What are the problems?
There's a lot, and I definitely
admit before writing my own SPV
wallet code, I
didn't think there
were a lot of problems with it.
I thought it was like, oh
this is SPV, this is cool.
This is how wallets work.
But when writing the code
myself, I'm like wait,
this is horrible.
What do we do?
OK, so the first thing you
do is you connect, you get
the headers, you verify them.
This is exactly
the same procedure
as what a full node does
so there's no difference,
it works.
No difference there.
The next step, you tell a
node all of your addresses.
What?
There goes all your
privacy, right,
because you're just
connecting to a computer.
You have no idea who they
are, who's running it,
and you're telling them hey,
here's all of my addresses,
and also here's how
much money I have.
Here's all my UTXOs.
You can lie.
You can add things
that are not--
you can also add some
addresses that aren't yours,
or add some UTXOs
that aren't yours,
and you'll get some
transactions back
that you can then
filter out on your own.
So you can you can raise
the rate of false positives
for that server.
And so there's these
Bloom filters that
are in the Bitcoin Core code.
They said the idea was
well, you can sort of
dial your own false
positive rate.
I'm not going to go
into Bloom filters work.
If you've used those
in other classes, cool.
But it basically
gives some data which
allows people to match things.
But they don't in practice
have good privacy.
You can create a Bloom
filter where they've
got 10% false positive rate.
And so when the server says, oh,
looks like their transaction,
maybe it's not because
10% of the time
it's just a false positive.
However, when you have
really high false positives,
you lose all the
efficiency savings of SPV
and it sort of
cascades where you've
got these false positives
and the server thinks,
oh, you got money, but
it's a false positive.
And they add that "you got
money" into the Bloom filter
itself and the Bloom
filter can really quickly
become saturated,
and then they just
start giving you everything.
So in practice, and
there's some papers
about how the people who put
the Bloom filters into Bitcoin
thought, oh this is good
for privacy, it's fine,
and in practice, it really
is not good for privacy.
So you end up basically telling
a node all your addresses.
And there's research on how
to do this in a better way,
and it's one of
those kind of things
where some random anonymous
person with a, I think,
inappropriate swear word email
address posted to the mailing
list and said, hey why don't
you guys do it this way?
And it was like,
oh, yeah, we should
have done it that way, oops.
The basic idea is instead
of creating a Bloom filter
as a client sending
it to a server,
basically instead of telling
the node all your addresses
and asking, what the nodes
will do-- the full nodes--
will create a Bloom filter
based on the entire block.
And then the client
can retrieve that,
match that against their
addresses, and see, hey,
did this block have
anything of interest to me?
And if so, request it--
much better privacy at a
pretty small cost in overhead.
And so, just no
one thought of it.
There's a lot of
things in Bitcoin
where it's like, no one thought
of it, we did something dumb.
And then something
better came out
and now we're working on it.
OK, so you tell the
node all your addresses.
That's a problem.
For each header, ask if you
gained or lost you UTXOs?
So can you think of
any problems here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could they lie
and not pay some of them?
TADGE DRYJA: Yup.
Easy to lie.
You just don't tell them.
If you're a server,
you just omit things,
and you can maybe mitigate
that by connecting
to a bunch of different
nodes but then
you lose even more
privacy because you've now
shared all your
addresses and money
with multiple anonymous nodes.
But it's really easy
to lie by omission.
Someone says, hey, here's
all my addresses, OK,
did I get any money?
Yup, yup.
And then you see one where
they got a bunch of money
and just don't tell them.
And they don't know.
This can be annoying in regular
wallets in the Lightning
Network stuff that
I work on that I'll
talk about, hopefully, later.
This can actually
be very damaging.
You can lose money
because of this.
But, in general, in Bitcoin,
you won't lose money
because you're not
aware of a transaction.
So this is also a problem,
easy to lie by omission.
The Merkle proofs help, but they
prove inclusion, not exclusion.
There's no way to
construct a proof that--
I'm going to I'm going
to give you proof
that I'm not omitting anything.
Although, with the idea of the
block-based filters sending,
there are ways to
construct that,
so it's even better
in that sense.
OK, so these are some of
the disadvantages of SPV.
Can anyone think of any
other problems with it, or--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: Fee estimation.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, OK.
So, yeah, you don't know--
since you're not
downloading the blocks,
you don't really know how much
fees other people are paying.
You're not verifying.
So even when you
get transactions,
you cannot verify any signatures
because you don't have UTXO
sets, so you just see that
it came from somewhere,
but you don't know if the
thing it's spending even exists
or has a key or anything, so
you can't verify the signature.
You don't know how much
money was coming in,
so even if you look
at the transactions,
you can't tell what
fees they're paying.
You sort of can if you
download the entire block.
There's ways around it,
but it's really ugly,
so it can be very
difficult to estimate fees.
So, in practice, you'd
probably ask the same server
that you've told
all your addresses
and all your UTXOs to,
hey, what fee should I use,
then they tell you that.
The idea is, well, if I ask five
people, hopefully, most of them
will be around the same.
So there's a bunch
of problems with SPV.
OK, so SPV sounds
pretty bad, right?
I think I'll stick
to my full node.
But is there anything
worse than SPV?
Asking for a friend.
Can I go worse?
So does anyone know
something we can
do that's worse security,
worse privacy than SPV
and that's also very popular?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
that's even worse.
But, yeah there's
a step in between.
So you can take out
some of these steps
where you just use an API
and you just ask people.
You have a website,
blockchain.info or Mycelium
Wallet, or bunch of wallets--
BitPay's, Copay,
things like that where
you don't verify
any headers, you
don't look at any
Merkle proofs, you just
skip right to the tell the
remote node all your addresses
and UTXOs and ask how much
money you've gained or lost.
So you've sort of outsourced
the entire process.
You don't store really
anything on your computer.
And you say, well, but you
do have your private keys.
You say, I made some private
keys, I made some addresses,
and then I tell this website,
hey, here's all my addresses,
how much money do I have?
And the servers responds,
yeah, you've got UTXOs, cool.
So then you can build
the transaction,
sign them, and send
them to the server.
So what are some advantages
and disadvantages of this?
There's probably some
obvious disadvantages, right?
Can anyone think of an
attack that this does not
help you against?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can just
make up transactions.
TADGE DRYJA: The server
can just say, hey,
you've got 1,000 Bitcoins.
You're like, awesome, but
it's just completely made up.
As the client, you
don't verify anything
about these transactions.
So that's a pretty big problem.
And the thing is, in
practice, one of the issues
is that people are
generally not as
aware of these types of
attacks because mostly people
worry about spending their
money, and they don't really--
merchants worry
about charge-backs
and worry about
receiving and verifying
that they've received
funds all the time,
but most people's experience
is they get paid once a month
or twice a month
with a paycheck,
and the money shows up in
their bank or whatever,
and they never really
worry about that.
They worry about
spending their money
and getting defrauded
or things like that.
So it's not something
a lot of people
think about all the time
is, did I actually get paid?
So there's easy
fraud that you can
do with this kind
of attack vector
where you sell a
car on Craigslist,
and someone comes and says,
yeah, I paid you the Bitcoins,
but they've actually
compromised the server
and you haven't
gotten paid at all.
But you think you have, so
you give over the goods.
So, yeah potential problems--
they can say you got paid when
you didn't, they can say you
lost money when you didn't.
And if it's in a browser,
that's even more fun
because they can
change the code.
The JavaScript is not
pinned to anything,
so if someone
compromises that server,
they can change the
code and potentially get
your private keys.
So you have, really,
very little security.
The blockchain is
not really providing
anything in this case.
However, this is
much more popular
than running a full or
SPV node, because you
know, blockchain.info,
you just sign in,
there's a lot of
wallets on the phones
that work this way as well.
And you do at least have
your private keys, hopefully.
So you've got that, right?
You're not giving custody
in any sense to them
but they learn a
lot of information.
OK, so not even SPV.
Can we do worse?
Yeah, so the Coinbase
company was an example
of "can we do worse?"
Yes, you can.
Someone else's coins is worse.
The case where my
dad said, hey can you
hold on to these coins
for me, it's worse.
He doesn't run a node, he
doesn't have his private keys,
he doesn't really understand
Bitcoin that well.
He wants to, but
he's busy and he's
like, hey, you know this
stuff, you deal with it.
You know way more
about this than I do.
I trust you since, you know,
we're dad and son and stuff
so not a huge trust problem
there, so I do it for him.
But you know, banks, right?
So the idea of a site or
an exchange or something
like this where you don't
even have your private keys.
You just have a website where
they run a node and a wallet
and they owe you the money.
It tends to end badly, and
even if it doesn't end badly,
it misses the point.
The whole idea of
Bitcoin was like, hey,
you can have your own money.
It's kind of cool.
It's running on your computer.
It feels like it's missing
the point to just hand it over
to some bank.
And it's not even a bank.
Most of these
sites, a big reason
why it tends to
end badly is there
aren't the same protections.
Banks have to do a lot of
work, and there's FDIC,
there's all sorts of
rules, and they also
build these big structures with
really heavy stone pillars,
so you're like, yeah, they can't
run off because this bank's not
going to move.
It's made out of rocks.
And the banks in Bitcoin do
not have big stone pillars.
IP addresses are really
easy to change and move
the computers around.
Another thing, they're
running a node,
right, these Bitcoin banks
that hold all your funds.
Sometimes they don't, so
these banks themselves
might run SPV nodes
or API things.
I don't want to name
any names, but there's
pretty good evidence that
big exchanges might even just
connect to an API and not
even run their own node.
Another-- there's a lot
of things like this where,
when something bad
doesn't happen,
people just keep pushing it--
where miners themselves don't
verify the blocks because they
think, well, he must have
created a valid block
and I'm not going to verify
it and everything works.
So the other thing is, while it
sounds really bad, in practice,
there haven't been really many
SPV attacks or API attacks.
We know of this, but in
practice it's hard to do.
If you want to defraud
someone by compromising
blockchain.info, you have to
compromise blockchain.info.
You don't have to do
all the proof of work,
because they're not validating
it, but it's still hard to do
and it requires a
coordinated active attacker
with quite a bit of resources.
And so when it doesn't
happen, people say,
well, SPV is just as good.
We don't have any evidence
of people being defrauded,
so it's just as good.
But that is kind of
dangerous because when
everyone starts
doing it, you start
to lose these protections.
Any questions about the
someone else's coins model?
There's all sorts
of legal issues.
There's a very long list
of ways it ends badly.
I don't know-- what is the half
life of a custodial exchange
in Bitcoin?
It's like a year or
two, and they drop off.
So why do people do this?
And here's a table of
trade-offs with these things.
It's mainly convenience, and so
that's a real reason to do it.
So if you're
running a full node,
you're going to have to
download at least 170 gigabytes.
That's a lot, right?
It's going to take a while.
Storage-- you're
going to have to store
at least 4 gigabytes long term.
And that's going up, but
not going up too much.
It's actually gone down
the last few weeks.
That's the UTXO set you
have to keep track of.
You don't have to keep
track of this 170 gigabytes.
It, by default, does but
you can turn on pruning.
But that's also super
user-unfriendly.
You have to edit a bitcoin.conf
file and type "pruning=500"
or something, and then save it,
and then it'll prune down to 4
gigs.
There's no-- at least,
that I'm aware of-- there's
no GUI nice menu thing
where you can say, hey,
I want to enable pruning.
I don't have to store it.
Speed-- on a really
nice computer,
it will take at least six
hours to download all this
and verify it.
That's pretty impressive
because it used to be more,
but that's still six hours.
People don't want
to deal with that.
Privacy-- certainly,
we can do better.
There's a lot of research on
how to make privacy and Bitcoin
better but this is what we got.
Security-- this is
as good as we've got
So then you go down to SPV.
Network-- you only have to
download about 50 megs, all
those headers.
If you've got a wallet
with lots of transactions,
you're going to download
100, 200, 300 megs
because you're going
to have to download
all the transactions that pay
you or you're paying out to.
Speed-- I said seconds, I think
I want to change it to minutes.
It's not that fast.
It's a lot faster.
I think seconds is
an exaggeration.
Well, it's like 60 seconds.
Anyway, it's pretty fast.
You download all the headers.
That takes the same
amount of time,
but that can be a
minute or two, and then
you're syncing the blocks.
It's really quick,
they're small.
Privacy is poor.
You lose a lot of
your privacy in SPV
because you're basically
telling random computers
on the internet, hey,
here's all my money.
Hey, here's all my addresses.
You're not completely
losing everything,
but it's pretty easy for actors
to reconstruct your wallet
from that.
Security-- medium.
I don't know, there haven't
been any real attacks on this,
but you're not verifying
the rules of Bitcoin.
If everyone's running
SPV, then a miner can say,
hey, I just generated
1,000 coins out of nowhere,
and no one's looking
for that transaction.
It only pays me,
and no one's going
to see that and
reject the block.
So if everyone runs
SPV, you're not
checking up on the miners,
which is a very real threat.
Miners do crazy stuff and you
got to watch out for them.
So, security-- questionable.
API query, where you
just ask a website hey,
here's all my addresses,
how much money do I have?
Network traffic-- I don't
know, less than a megabyte.
You have to load the
websites and stuff
but it's pretty light.
Storage-- you basically
don't have to store anything.
I mean, you have to
store your private keys,
but those can be password-based
and derived on the fly.
Speed-- like a second, right.
It's real quick.
You're making an HTTP query,
you're getting a response,
you're parsing it,
it's real quick.
Privacy is poor.
It's worse than SPV, but
because it's really easy
because you just hand them
over all your addresses
in the clear.
And security is also quite
poor, in that they can say hey,
you got money or you
lost money, and you just
accept what they say.
Hold my key-- this
is network traffic.
I don't know, you have to
go to a website, I guess.
There's no storage, there's
no speed, there's no privacy,
there's no security.
You're just handing the entire
thing off to someone else.
So what would you guys
guess are the popularity
of the different models?
Most popular to least popular.
Yeah, this is definitely
the most popular.
Second most, third
most, fourth most.
Everyone does this, a few people
do this, some people do this,
and a couple thousand
people do this.
It's a problem, and
this is something
that is one of the ongoing
problems, not just in Bitcoin.
Ethereum would be
a little different,
but still, it's going
to be a lot of this.
Ethereum has a
weird different SPV.
There's other models.
There's one in the
middle for Ethereum
that's also quite popular.
It's like SPV with
UTXO commitment.
Well, no, I guess it
would be more here.
Anyway, I'm not going
to go into Ethereum.
But it's a problem and there's
different ways to attack it.
One of the issues is
that a lot of people
who program Bitcoin itself
really only focus on this,
and they say, look,
this is not our problem.
We can't solve this.
We're going to try to
make this-- the way
we're going to
try to solve this,
is let's try to
get the speed down.
If it takes days, people
are going to move this way.
If it takes hours, maybe
a lot of people will say,
hey I was using SPV, but yeah,
it's not too bad running this.
I'm going to run this and
get the more security.
Let's try to keep
this number down.
Let's try to keep speed down.
Let's try to improve privacy
and security of the full node.
That is generally what most
of the Bitcoin Core developers
focus on, which I
don't argue with.
But it does lead to some neglect
of SPV, where there's not--
it's been over a year, year
and a half, almost two years
where we know how to make
SPV better and more secure,
but there's not a lot
of enthusiasm and people
working on it.
And people argue about the
security of these things.
This, there's not
much you can do.
I mean, there is kind of
cryptography research like,
hey, is there some cool way I
can send you all my addresses
so that you can figure out how
much money I have without you
learning all my addresses?
That's called private
information retrieval,
and there's all sorts
of papers on that.
In practice, there
aren't any that use that.
And this, well, yeah multi-sig.
That's more like regulation.
Can we have restrictions and
rules on these, essentially,
banks to try to make
it safer, maybe?
These are the two where software
development can definitely help
make this a lot easier to use.
So we can encourage people
to use it, but most people--
security is hard because
most people, if you don't
see a problem, this is a lot
easier, and a lot of people
think, well, I'm not
good at computers, so--
they are, and it's safer
if I give all my money
to someone else.
In some cases, it could be true.
But that has systemic
effects where now you've
got these five
computers in the world,
and if you're able
to compromise those,
they have just
billions of dollars
worth of Bitcoins on them.
And so that's why black
hat hacker kind of people,
it's like the best thing to do.
It's like, there's
a computer somewhere
and it's got a billion
dollars of untraceable money
that I can just steal.
Like, it's-- what
could be better?
Yeah, I could get
everyone's passwords.
That's cool.
Or yeah, I could
read people's emails.
Whatever.
Or, I can just steal
a billion dollars.
So what do you think
they're going to do?
So this leads to
huge concentrations
of coins in a very
small number of nodes,
and people try to attack it.
So this is sort of the
landscape we're in now.
It's certainly not ideal.
There's a lot of technology
that's pretty good
that's not being used.
There's a lot of
technology that's
crummy that's being used a lot
and how we make this stronger
and faster, how to
make this faster,
things like that are really
interesting research areas.
Almost done.
Wallets are fun, but
usability issues.
If you want to try
testing out wallets
you can try downloading them,
playing around with them.
They often leave quite
a bit to be desired.
The one I work on, Lit, leaves
enormous amounts to be desired.
It's all in text.
And Ethan should
be here Wednesday
and good luck with
the problem set.